I'm
uh so merch remember Taryn Manning she
was in Orange is the New Black yeah yeah
yeah
and also the one that we that was in
that Karen movie that we played the
trailer remember that Karen movie okay
um I I found this and I this this is
everyone we got to bring this to the
main show so I found this on day away
but we got to bring it here and here it
is
this is her now I want you to listen to
this first off oh I don't have the song
queued up what drugs is she on secondly
what the [__] third it's not like she's
not working she still gets work there's
shitty movies but she has money check
this out
so I had to pull over because I'm just
like I don't want to like cause crosses
crosses so rude is right now
so
whoa what drugs are we thinking so far
I booze
I think it's that she's lacking the
drugs that she's usually on okay get
ready
it gets good the man that I've been
messing with messing with the married
man
the man that I've been messing with is a
married man
got divorced hey really quick Royce I'm
on her Wikipedia right so first of all
grew up trans so she's trailer trash
yeah 100 uh she actually has like she
has like diagnosed like alcohol abuse
like she has like she's gone in and out
of rehab she's this booze she is a
alcohol hardcore alcoholic well watch
this but this gets even better the
for about 3
to licking his butthole
um what a woman
she's not all bad
no so it's not Meth mouth
because you liked it
why would hope you're licking his bug as
he liked it not against his will yeah
that would be awesome no stop stop her
her mouth is a cacophony of bacteria
am I doing it is that does that bother
is that weird yeah
that is what
demons do so I it's a demon that's what
demons do
we go all the
all the beaches
whoever this guy's an absolute Chad this
he's ugly as [__] I get it but he's
using her having her licking on a float
and ate his ass it's free this guy rolls
this guy whoever he is
this baby we gotta go to Newport Beach I
need a boat
I was you think he was like you think he
was like bent over like reading [__]
reading the boat catalog like a [__]
16 year old girl reading a clothing
catalogy it was just power washing his
[__] with her tongue yeah he was he
was bent over his
clicking through through like boats
boats come
she's touching on him with his ass like
a [__] earicorn
we go all the way
I was so in love so I thought so I could
buy this job and then he took off on the
bus
I put it down foreign
[Music]
and his wife because he's married and I
feel so bad because not I I can't feel
sorry
do you I can't stand her her his wife
she wasn't even like wait what you've
been messing with my nephew she said you
lunatic you get out of my life bro I'll
get an RO on you training order
no I'll put your ass in jail anyway so
I've been licking your man's butthole
for weeks on in because
wow
maybe I love her I I can't tell she's
growing up she's perfect but she's
terrifying well for weeks on end because
he he likes it a lot and I do it to him
and he comes to me and it happens
what is going on here
oh
that's a lot I know it's a lot of
information but I'm the lunatic nice car
though I know that's what I'm saying
she's not broke I'm telling you she's
not broke she's about to go buy a boat
cash so she had cash on her to go buy a
boat right
now I'm just single very single
and he came to me so you don't accuse me
of being a lunatic but I'll tell you one
thing when you want to put me in jail
I'll put you in jail so fast your head
will be spinning don't you ever threaten
me
ma'am you were licking her husband's
[__] how did you rep why did you want
her to react to this
bro that would be one of those things
she doesn't did anything illegal like
she said hey stop [__] my husband or
my restraining order you hear me out
here's my theory
even bigger than this because my theory
is even better than this
I because the wife that he's recording
her didn't get married her husband just
got mad at her
the husband and wife were in on this
together
they knew think about this let's think
about this
she's ugly as [__] so it's not because
she's hot right they knew she had money
she's drunk she was an easy mark this
guy's probably decent looking enough
dude right the wife is like look you go
out there let it lick your [__]
whatever right let it do whatever I
don't give a [__] as soon as you sign
that [__] title to the boat I'll come
and swing in a bag yes everybody [__]
husband exactly as soon as we get a boat
but like I'm telling you brilliant it
means it's not bad like we think about
it's a good plan right she you know
she's a drunk like that was easily
brought up she was drunk she she's
easily manipulated she's lonely she's
single she has a [__] a bunch of
money doesn't know what to do with it
the husband and wife went in it together
this was like this is a clear scam in my
opinion honey trap exactly
that's what I'm thinking I mean even if
it even if it wasn't even if he was
actually cheating this would be the
easiest cheating to get out of you'd be
like baby come on she's lick my [__]
it's pretty funny and we got a boat you
gotta admit it's funny and we we got a
yacht now so
what are you gonna do right
look if you don't want to kiss me for a
few weeks I get it I understand
I was so
no she said I'm gonna show you how I do
so I'm like wait you're gonna eat her
butthole that's what she's gonna do yes
on a boat though
yeah I will show you how I do
don't you ever threaten me when your
husband came to me to get his butthole
licked
it's my favorite line me again Leanne
you dumbass what are you thinking I
would let her lick my ass if I got a
boat out of it I mean it's very low risk
on my end yeah I mean you're not really
doing much of anything no I'm getting a
boat and getting my ass licked
you don't even have to have a boner to
get your ass licked
amen how funny would it be to like swing
your dick down and hit her in the chin
and make her bite her tongue
[Laughter]
I cannot believe you Virgie thinks she
has teeth
I mean she does she like she takes them
out at night but she's got teeth lost it
not I
not I I brought your husband to Newport
Beach we drove all the way together we
had so much fun he had his hand on my
leg the whole time most of the time
finger banging me am I still I'm not
gonna lie anymore about about it
to quote sex Ferguson that's cause
you're a mark by the way I like how she
goes finger banging me and I'm not gonna
lie about anymore you started with
[__] eating anything after that it's
like finger banging it's nothing
compared to [__] eating you know what
I mean yeah I mean you kind of really
escalated immediately you front loaded
it which by the way sitting in probably
unescaled front loaded that huh and
and every time like in his fingers and
you're to buy him a boat
to buy him a boat and all day we went on
a boat the boat that he wants and I was
gonna buy it for him and then he
messed up real bad today
and you're coming after me nah ain't
gonna happen lady
uh Carlos says this [__] looks like she
should have a podcast on gas digital you
made a huge mistake in the name of
your dusted dusted I ain't scared of you
ma'am that's the video
um she tweeted out an apology she's
doing good she tweeted on an apology let
me read her apology here for what she's
out here
[Applause]
he oats what is she apologizing for not
buying me one
um
Taryn Manning over the past few days
I've done some time to reflect on the
situation I've been dealing with I was
deeply hurt and handled things on a
public platform when I should have dealt
with them quietly and while I get
support of my close friends and family I
felt a lot of guilt after exposing
everything and thought maybe the best
solution to the situation would be to
say I lied about it all but that's not
the truth oh no she's doubling down holy
[__] here we go I started a relationship
with somebody who was married and told
me he would leave his wife in the end I
found out that was impossible I pride
myself on being an ethical and kind
person I know what I did was wrong but
the heart makes you do crazy things
sometimes I'm sorry for exposing my
situation I am not sorry for how I love
I hope to find somebody who could
cherish me the way I adore them he loves
[__]
she really loves the butts yeah for real
dude a healthy type of love and a love
that isn't so blind that it forces me to
be somebody I'm not this is a huge
Learning lesson for me with all this
said I'm asking everyone to please give
me privacy so I can heal and amend my
heart
and brush your teeth probably brush your
teeth would be really important part of
this
wow this [__] is
[__] nuts